russian soldiers picked their way
through the rubble of what used to be an
apartment block in siviera donetsk
russia was in control of more than 70
percent of this small industrial city in
the east of the country but in recent
days ukraine's military says it's
reclaimed some of the territory and
accuses russia of blowing up bridges to
prevent them bringing in reinforcements
and aid
in the donetsk direction the enemy is
shelling positions of our troops along
the entire line of contact with mortars
cannon and rocket artillery it uses
operational tactical and army aviation
the main efforts are concentrated on the
siviro donetsk and bachmud directions
fighting continues in the city in
donetsk russian shelling sparked a major
fire at a famous wooden monastery it's
one of ukraine's most sacred orthodox
sites
it caught fire as a result of a russian
artillery attack this was not the first
attack on wednesday three monks were
killed by russian shelling
in ukraine's second largest city kharkiv
a civilian airfield has been damaged by
a missile strike the city has suffered
sporadic attacks since ukrainian forces
regained territory and pushed back
russian troops earlier this month
as fighting continues the u.s has
promised to support ukraine's
investigations into alleged war crimes
by russian forces
i think one of the challenges is that
there are a lot of cases
and how do you prioritize and order them
and do them in the midst of a country in
war
yeah there are a lot of challenges but
that won't deter us
a war that's not expected to end anytime
soon military experts say both sides
face a prolonged war of attrition in the
east of ukraine in the coming months
victoria gatenbee al jazeera